dear Sarah thank you for your question
it's one question that many people have
been asking both on the policy level a
journalistic level but also just amongst
everyday people it is uncountable that
foreign policy drives a lot of the anger
that Arabs Muslims feel towards the u.s.
mainly because of the u.s. is support
for Israel at times when it's been clear
that the positions that Israel have been
taken are unjust and unfair however
beyond just that basic political point I
think often the US has tried to do
social engagement has tried to do
economic incentives to move beyond the
political disagreements the problem is
is you cannot hide over the problems by
creating nice cozy little projects that
will keep a certain group of people
happy because after a while the actual
effects wear off I do believe that
President Obama's speech about a new
beginning between Muslim and Arab
Muslims and Americans got a lot of
people excited however they saw that in
terms of implementation still things did
not happen so to actually tackle this
there's two sides the first is to deal
with the political issues and not think
that you can cover over them by little
projects or little initiatives but on
the other hand the way that you can
actually solve this is to have true
partnerships local partners between
Americans and Arabs wherever they are in
the region and to work on local projects
that benefit both sides what it should
be is a partnership not handouts not aid
just give them for the sake of aid to
cover up political messes rather true
partnership between the two and
I moved recently to Washington I'm an
Iraqi living in Washington what I've
learned is that we actually have so much
in common more than the differences we
have whether it's relative relative ly
conservative societies or a true a true
society based on beliefs and values
there are not too different from one
another so I think once we build the
trust and once we agree that the
political differences are important and
you can't glide over them I think we can
move forward together